all right Disney we know that you are
probably the best at creating memorable
movie characters but what is the deal
with canceling some of these guys before
we ever get to see them we wonder what
goes on in the studio's that makes you
decide that a character has to go are
you going to bring back any forgotten
characters in the remakes we'd love to
see them in action they've been on the
back burner for way too long
Disney has been creating amazing
characters for decades but not every
character makes it to your screen check
out these 10 cancelled Disney characters
that you never got to see breaker the
dolphin Ariel from The Little Mermaid
was almost a very different character
her adventurous spirit was originally
seen in her best friend
his name was breaker the dolphin but
breaker was ultimately cut from the
movie they decided to make Ariel a
stronger character some of her best
lines actually belong to breaker in the
early versions of the script supposedly
the dancing dolphin in under the sea is
breaker but we don't even get to know
his name how cool would a dolphin BFF be
shakes the rattle can you imagine a baby
toy being too scary for a Disney movie
that's exactly what happened to Toy
Story a toy bring was supposed to talk
about how cruel Sid was patient is rich
he described his old friends shakes the
rattle then he said that shakes ended up
in SIDS yard no one knew what happened
but they heard shakes
screams apparently the dialogue was too
scary for Pixar's first film it was cut
from the final version we knew Sid was
messed up Wow me too and body we never
really got to see Nala grow up in the
Lion King but in the original script she
had her own gang of friends lots of
characters were cut from the first
versions including meat soo and body
me too was a lion cub who is knowledge
little brother body was a bat eared Fox
they were comedic relief much like Timon
and Pumbaa of course who's the brains of
this outfit it was decided that they
weren't necessary to the story so they
were cut Nina and Mara the emperor's new
group was almost a very different story
originally the emperor was going to
switch bodies with a peasant boy named
pata Ozma was then going to turn the
real emperor into a llama Nina was the
Emperor's fiancee who hated him but she
falls in love with pata after the switch
Mata was a llama
who falls in love with the Emperor but
when the story got more comedic the love
stories were cut Mona's brothers in the
first versions of the Moana story she
was going to have some brothers that got
lost at sea she was the best at sailing
but still overlooked by her father until
she saved her brothers but we aren't
talking about one or two brothers I've
already beaten the Middle's Moana was
going to have nine of them whoa this is
a lot of characters instead of just
cutting the numbers of brothers down all
of them were canceled and the whole
story changed
red feather the turkey Pocahontas has
one of the cutest animal companions ever
in Miko but the Native American princess
was originally going to have another BFF
he was a talking Turkey named red
feather he was going to be super
sarcastic and hilarious the directors
wanted him to be voiced by actor John
Candy but the actors too oddly passed
away instead of recasting the role red
feather was cut from the whole movie
they also made none of the animals talk
in the final version think that's a big
change
stay tuned to find out what other
character was totally cut from a Disney
film Hiawatha speaking of Pocahontas did
you know that there was almost another
Native American Disney movie way back in
the 1940s Disney planned to release a
full-length film called Hiawatha it was
going to be a sequel to the short called
a little Hiawatha this mighty warrior
Hiawatha was one of the founders of the
Iroquois Confederacy there is an epic
poem about him written in the 1800s the
film was ultimately scrapped and Disney
didn't make another Native American
character until the 1990s we're glad we
finally got a native Disney protagonist
this is the path I choose father the
music box in the original Beauty and the
Beast Belle was supposed to have her
mother's music box
her father was going to sell it when he
was captured by the Beast I'll give you
a place to stay but at the castle the
music box was going to come alive it was
supposed to replace chip as the cute
character and speak through music notes
alone and he was supposed to be an
important part of the movie but it was
cut in the live-action movie Belle's
father makes music boxes there's also an
enchanted piano it's good to know that
the music box idea came back years later
Harold the mermen in the Little Mermaid
we were supposed to see how
Ursula was before Ariel got involved
with her he is the deal Harold was a
nerdy mer man who wanted to impress the
mermaids but Ursula tricked him and
turned him into a polyp Harold was cut
from the story when the movie became too
long but the directors loved his
character and he was a character I think
we both personally related to do you
think Harold will make an appearance in
the new live-action Little Mermaid that
would be so cool
Aladdin's mom a lion is another Disney
movie that cut a character to completely
change the plot Aladdin was supposed to
be a younger character he was stealing
to support his family but his mother was
disappointed in him he spins the movie
trying to make her proud he uses the
genie to become a prince to impress her
there was even a whole song about his
mom but the film's creators decided to
scrap her entire storyline it became a
love story instead also magic and
Aladdin joined the ranks of orphaned
Disney characters which of these Disney
characters do you wish had been saved
tell us in the comments thanks for
watching give us a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the things so you never
miss another video see you next time
[Music]